in our previous terraforming Mars
playthrough we showed you the
terraforming Rush strategy now we're
going to look at the second major
approach to winning which is to build an
engine and draw out the game I'll be
talking strategy with a skilled Danish
player boneless to look at his decisions
in this game and to show you how he got
such an incredibly high score this is
this is legendary tactics
all right we're here today with boneless
for a huge game this one you are showing
us how to maximize your engine so tell
me about your corporation Choice here
your Prelude cards and your opening card
choice
yeah
um I'm for sure we're going for Luna
because this is a two-player game the
other Corporation went that good and
then I had one Prelude with an earth tag
so I'm picking that one and then all I'm
thinking about now is just get the most
card draw the most engine as humanly
possible okay I own the contractor I
research project
so um right off the bat uh this game is
gonna be first of all insane and it's
also gonna be really fast paced because
I already cropped this down to one hour
uh I think I kind of had to because
otherwise this video would be far too
long so perfect so in 60 minutes or less
you're gonna get a crazy amount of
content in here yeah so so Point Luna
let's start with that what what's your
uh Focus there with that's on titanium
is it
well yeah I get 17 in production but
mainly the strength of this Corporation
is to get to draw a card every time I
play an earth tag and this is like one
of the best corporations in two player
games it's all it's it's always a good
cooperation but especially in two player
games you're like inclined to go for
these long greedy strategies with like a
lot of card grow right so if you're
having a lot of Car Pro then obviously
you'll see more Earth attack which means
that the Luna Corporation is just gonna
do more for you so it's uh it's a very
good cooperation for for this game and
also had a starting hand with with some
Prelude and some some cards with like a
earth attack so it's a it was a
no-brainer for sure I'm gonna go for
this you got orbital construction for
your Prelude right and that that also
was to do with titanium
uh I think so I think I had a a one with
titanium and then I had this Omni
contractor which had an earth tag and
three points or something so yeah right
yeah okay now in terms of the initial
card Choice out of the 10 how many do
you usually take in a a big game like
this where you know you're going for a
long game well pretty much just what the
biggest engine possible so I take all
the mega credit all the all the steel
production or titanium production all
the discount cards all the cap draw all
of this is stuff I'm looking at and of
course I'm more inclined to go for Earth
tax because I have this Corporation so I
believe I got one of the Earth Tech
cards that also Bros maker so there's a
lot of good things in the starting hand
and obviously if if you're gonna get a
big score like this you need to be very
lucky and this is for sure a very lucky
game on my pad well it's partly luck but
it's also partly creating luck for
yourself too we talked about this with
wig spin where you know you can't get a
score like this purely based on I mean I
would never get the score no matter how
lucky I am because I just don't have the
skill with the synergies yet yeah
I picked up some really nice cards here
so that's an interesting choice here I'm
I'm choosing uh space station and then I
am uh what's my point with this because
I remember there was a choice between
playing Iron mining Industries or just
playing the Earth catapult I think I
went for the Earth catapult before yeah
I did because now I have two discounted
old cards
um I it was like a really tough choice
because sometimes it's actually better
to play Iron Man Industries and then
just do that this generation then the
next Generation you can start playing
Earth catapult and not just get a large
discount going but in this case I had
some other cars I believe I had like a
one more titanium production a lot of a
few cheap cards so I think I did it like
this
these hackers is a questionable card but
I think it's a two-player game it's a
little bit better and also this is uh
still early enough that it's it's uh
it's okay
you're looking to just uh yeah you're
looking at the Miranda Resort there
oh yeah yeah for sure uh this is like
the best topic I could have had it's
like perfect
nice so um that's to increase your make
oh wow you're up to nine uh yeah exactly
yeah yeah I think it gave me six or
something crazy because I just had so
many Earth attacks in my early game so
it's a
it's very lucky so so this goes back to
the fact that I didn't play Iowa mining
Industries now now it ended up being
like a lot better because now I actually
played some Earth tags and that picked
up Miranda's Resort and stuff like this
yeah oh wow okay so so sometimes the
sequence in the order is is really
um governs what you're gonna choose next
basically it is for sure so right here
Rover construction I kind of want to
keep this card but the thing is I want
to play Iron Man industry so if you do
the math it's it's only add up to 38 and
the iron mining industry is going to
cost 37 so I can't actually buy this
card I just looked at Rover construction
yeah okay so so this is just my
generation I just spent my generation uh
playing these Iron Man Industries and
that's fine wow this is early to be
looking at Milestones is it not
yeah a little bit I don't think I would
be picking them up yet but I can still
like plan ahead which one am I actually
gonna go for because already now I know
that I have a dream game yeah so so um I
don't wanna I Don't Wanna Give him too
many points I'm feeling all right this
I'm I'm just gonna crush this guy it's a
it's it should be fine but it's funny
you mentioned like order of of witch
cups to play it and stuff like this
um so so I also have in my hand I
believe this card
um
uh what's called Marsh University
um and you might be thinking this is a
perfect card to play in the early game
because it can allowed me to rotate up
but the thing is I haven't started
playing my my science text yet so I'm
actually waiting to play this card until
I plan on playing more science tags
right okay so yeah you're right there's
a lot of different uh the order of which
you play cards are really important for
sure yeah your income here is awesome
yeah I just I just picked up another
Earth Tech gold amplifier what was it
cartel or something so yeah
yeah it's a oh it's a dream game man it
really is yeah yeah I dream of having
that kind of production one thing I
struggle with is I always feel like I'm
I'm short on the the mega credit income
so am I doing something wrong or uh am I
just not getting the right cards or what
what are you doing to get up to 11 here
I guess is my question
um first of all being lucky uh second of
all there is a little bit of
optimization you can do you can like not
keep as many of the cops that are not
useful for you but this is like it's
it's hard to you have to look at a game
and like have to pinpoint what's
actually the thing I want to do with my
cars
so it's uh I would say without hurting
your feelings it's probably a little bit
of both but mostly mostly of course the
only reason I can get this insane Engine
5 titanium and 11 make a credit
production at this point that's because
I'm lucky obviously yeah what would be
the lowest income you would see yourself
running the game with like do you ever
run with like two or zero or uh
sometimes you do it just out of like
because you you literally have nothing
sometimes you just have a dead hand
um but even then if you're like playing
with colonies you can like compensate
for this but when we are playing on the
mass app here it's we don't have
colonies right so I think
a thing that I would really do in every
game I would really try to at least get
10 uh money income that could be like
Mega credits or 10 more
terraform rating or something so you at
least have 30 uh gold to start the
generation with rather than only the 20
you have like to begin with you you kind
of need to get out of this of this hole
in the early game you really need to to
climb out of there because otherwise
it's uh it's got a really hard to play
the game absolutely
it's cool how you can generate income in
different ways though in this game I
love that yeah for sure yeah
so that that's a lot of different ways
to do it especially if you have more
expansions if you have colonies there's
like even more different choices you
have to make with with the colonies
so yeah oh there's that imported ghg we
talked about that in the shorter game
coverage yeah yeah the funny thing is
now I'm keeping it for an entirely
different reason first of all I'm just
keeping four cards here because I had a
dream game and I have this uh uh what's
it called uh Martian University so just
by keeping forecasts I have more bad
cards in my hand just so I can rotate
those with Marsh University
but the reason this card you just
mentioned is also really good right now
is because it has a Nerf tag and it's
already really cheap so it's uh it will
always it would also draw me a card with
my cooperation Point Luna
so yeah it's really good now but for
entirely different reasons than the last
game which is kind of funny
now when you buy Milestones early like
that do you sort of tip your hand to
your opponent of what your strategy is
going to be or would you ever want to
hold on and not reveal what you're
planning
I don't think it says so much about your
strategy if they want to look at your
strategy that just like look at your
your game look at what you're you're
doing how much plant and heat production
do you have would you just scroll
through the Milestone you can see what
people have anyway right so by actually
buying it don't give that much away I
don't think but the thing is uh buying
them
too early could be a problem in these
long greedy two-player games but right
now we are in generation six six so uh I
think I'm already bought the one with 16
cards I think that was also because now
I'm down to 15 cards so I just wanted to
buy that while I actually had the cars
to do so right
and the other Milestones I I believe I'm
gonna check them out sooner or later but
the
I don't think there's there's one he's
close to yet so even though I can
actually buy a milestone right now I
would imagine I I probably have the
Builder close to the builder at this
point but even though I have that I'm
not even I'm not even gonna buy it until
I have to until he's close to buying one
right so yeah that's that's a lot of
it's a little bit more efficient this
way yeah right just to use your your
income like actively on the board as
opposed to in something that's just
sitting there doing nothing yeah exactly
it said Mega credits you could spend on
engine instead of spending it on well it
basically nothing when it comes to
engine it will make the no difference if
you if you pick up the Milestone now or
in the Next Generation so if you can get
away with it this is the way to go
does this game ever have a problem with
people like looking at your engine and
saying oh my gosh this guy is just
crushing me and like I've got to sit
here for another hour playing against
like what's gonna be certain Doom is is
there a big attrition rate of people
dropping out of games or uh I think
would you play on the app here for
example it's not that bad because it's
uh the game is gonna be over rather
quickly but in real life if you're uh it
happens sometimes that you're all right
this is lost and you just have to like
wait for a long time before people
actually finish but the it's not
interested in mention it because in this
game in particular
um at this point I already know that I
won the game this is like there's no
question so I'm I'm thinking uh it's a
little bit rude for me to just go for
14th generation because the game is
obviously over but what's gonna end up
happening is my opponent is gonna leave
the game so I just end up playing
against an AI so in that case I'm like
well now now I'm not being rude now now
I can just 14th generation just have
some fun so that's pretty much what
happened in this game so so if if my
opponent didn't leave I wouldn't
actually have had a game with this big
score but this this one wouldn't have
yeah
right so yeah that's that's that
consideration sometimes for sure
yeah the world junior hockey
championship is on now and yeah they
just let the scores run up in those
because oh my God you are so Canadian
yeah the tiebreaker is yeah I hate when
that happens but uh that's all right so
and if people haven't seen our other
video I'll link to that now and at the
end of the video
um the other one is an example of the
rush play this is an example of the
engine building but you also on your
channel uh boneless DOTA have all kinds
of videos on this now you've sort of
surged with your strategy guides so um
what what do you cover in those
um everything
um it's uh I'm bad at doing something
halfway so so for this project I just
went all in I just so I have uh I don't
know maybe 10 or 20 hours of of content
just for a strategy guide it's it's like
way too much but I just wanted to cover
everything so we have a few games like
this one where just went for the
different strategies there's gonna be
um some of the same replays we're
covering here and also some some City
and some like a jovian assassin system
and also it's gonna be it's just gonna
be a strategy guide with uh first of all
there's gonna be a lot of tips to help
win so I'll have two of those videos and
then that's gonna cover all the
strategies uh and there's gonna be some
stuff about the best synergies in the
game and timings and it's gonna be a
yeah a lot of different things that
for sure oh brilliant okay so yeah
you're getting all kinds of greenery
here
yeah
oh and this one is actually kind of
funny so this Greenery looks really bad
but nobody has a city or rather I don't
have a city on the map yet so I can't
place my Greenery next to it but yeah
this is the reason I wanted to play
nitrogen Rich asteroid so I needed to
put down this Plantation in order to
play this car so for sure this is the
correct Choice even though it looks a
little bit ugly to just place a Greenery
that is not next to my city
so tell me about when you would want to
use Mega credit versus when you want to
decrease the cost with your Titanium or
or your other resources
um how do you decide what the balance is
there
I think it's pretty straightforward if
you have titanium steel you want to use
it it could be some cases where you also
have like Advanced LS in your hand in
this case you have to be a little bit
careful because then you still could a
titanium could increase in value there's
also a few other cars with consideration
where you might actually need the the
Steeler titanium but but mostly you just
want to use it when you can because
these resources can only be used for
building a SpaceX oh okay gotcha
and what's going what's going through
your mind here so you're you're in a
good position would you say we're into
mid game
yeah I mean if we look at the other game
we just had like a game was over on
generation eight right that's right it
moves so quickly these two player games
are so fast Yeah well yeah yeah
depending on how you look at it I would
say that five player games is so fast in
terms of generations right because uh uh
in a two-player game it's it's uh it's
gonna be longer in terms of generations
so that's this is why I tend to favor
this greedy craft strategy in two player
games which this is definitely it um I'm
keeping all the cards I can get I even
wanted to get even more card draw I'm
not getting enough for my liking and
also I obviously I built like the
biggest engine ever so it's uh this this
is the defining factor of the car
strategy
it's brilliant
yeah now I'm finally getting a city on
the map I even picked up like a stand-up
project and the reason is uh I have a
lot of cards in my hand but but none of
them are like
perfect for for this uh situation right
now I I feel like I had the the enough
money to actually buy this city and it's
also kind of nice because then I could
place a Greenery next to it and it's a
pretty good placement for a city and a
pretty a very good placement for the
greenery next to it so I can get like a
lot of water adjacency and one Steel
so it makes a lot of sense to just pick
this up now and
now I'm definitely it's uh it's kind of
weird that nobody's actually claimed the
last Milestones yet but I'm just keeping
track of my how far my opponent is in
that regard yeah okay yeah
so Milestones definitely the next thing
I want to be doing maybe the first of
all just locking those in
yeah and now we hit the mid game
um so for sure now I'm really beginning
to think I'm making the transition from
just building a lot of engine now around
now on VP so so first I'm getting
decomposers and then I I picked up in my
hand you could see a lot of green tags
so this is the next
point of the menu I just want to play
all of these green tags this is what I
want to do now
how do you make that decision of when to
go from building your engine to now
converting on it
um generally speaking in the early game
you build engine in the late game you
build a VP in this case it's also more
like I don't have that much engine lift
I have six titanium so that could go
either soleta or it could be the uh
immigration shuttles so so and other
than that I don't really have any engine
left so I think it's a good point it's a
good part of the game to just really try
to go for some some VP
yeah okay and part of your final score
must depend on when you actually make
that pivot
transition yeah yeah for sure because if
you transition too late then you got
this great engine that didn't actually
do anything for you and if you
transition too early then you lose out
on the maximum
um sort of income levels to generate PP
yeah and that's exactly the the mistake
that a lot of new players are making
they just keep making engine for the
entire game right yeah
guilty right now Advanced allies I just
picked this up so this is perfect so
this is why I I waited until uh spending
some of my titanium because I could see
that I could draw a few cars with I
don't know how Earth takes or something
or my actions right um okay and right
here it's perfect because I haven't
spent my sixth titanium yet so Advanced
allies and then I can play one of my
expensive titanium cards that's perfect
oh nice
so I hate to do this to you but uh I'm
more of a wingspan my wingspan player
myself and I think for me it never felt
really overwhelming even though there's
tons and tons of birds in that whereas
with terraforming Mars I sometimes feel
like this game is just there's so much
going on but of the two which which game
do you prefer and why
oh it's a really hard question I think
both of them are really great excellent
games and both of them are engine
building the differences that in
terraform us you can have a little more
fun with your engine you can build a
nice engine wingspan but then the game
is Just immediately over right
um
so slight favorites to terraform your
mouse but you know me I've played a lot
of games in both so obviously I love
both games so
it's good yeah yeah this one just seems
like I wouldn't pull terraforming Mars
out at a family gathering but I would
pull wing span out because
it might be just the theme but uh well
also the complexity uh when everything
is said and done wingspan is a lot
easier to to change it's more like a
Gateway game terraforming Mouse it's a
lot of rules and also the biggest thing
is like for new players this takes like
three or four hours maybe to to play a
game especially if you have to explain
the rules first so yeah and the strategy
is a lot more complex than this because
there's a lot more sort of interlinking
approaches that you can there's more
options I would say whereas with
wingspan it's a little bit more linear
yeah I would I would say that the yeah
for sure in in wingspan I get like oh
yeah Central Pool and wingspans I could
like
lose a game to anyone if if they maybe
not his first game but but if he or she
like had maybe a few games and they were
just very lucky and I was very unlucky
in wingspan that's like little you can
do right yes
but in terraforming mass is basically
impossible to to lose to someone who's
new to the game if you're very
experienced at the game because there's
so many different paths to victories and
like you said the complexity is just so
high yeah yeah and I think that's what
makes some of those family-friendly or
Gateway games so popular is that it's
it's not a predetermined winner based on
skill or experience yeah that's a good
thing so some people like one of my
friends he doesn't like lock in board
games and I try to explain him then you
should play chess or something it's a
rock is part of the game and it's what
makes it fun in a lot of cases so right
you have to overcome the uh the
impediments that are placed in front of
you yeah yeah
but to get back to the game here
um
I believe
I end up making a lot of points on green
tax energy so so this is definitely what
I've been starting to build up right now
yeah and so so I think decomposers and a
little bit later I also get the
ecological Zone and maybe also violent
enhances I haven't really been paying
attention but some of these cards are
actually you shouldn't underestimate how
many points these cards can actually
give you it's it's you'll see at the end
of this game it is quite insane how many
points you can get on these cards so you
probably don't remember the exact
numbers but where do you think the
majority of your points are coming from
in this game then just on the greenery
Cuts cuts for sure I mean if you also
like I think it's gonna be like maybe 54
points on top of cards just from Green
text and and other things I put on top
of my cards and then the card itself is
going to be another 100 points right I
think okay maybe 170 points
it's just from cards
so that's for sure where the majority of
no actually I think I said this wrong
because I think the way they calculated
is they they um
I think it's only going to be 110 points
on cards actually because I think the 54
points that I'm talking about those are
part of the the the the card
um
like like here you can see I have 15
victory points on cards I think this is
things on top of my cars also included
so I think I said it wrong I accepted it
a little bit I think I just have 110
points on cards when everything is
hidden up well they'll have to watch
through to the end to find out
yeah yeah we'll see for sure
so this is the AI hard has jumped in now
for the uh for Mississippi I I don't I
don't I don't blame uh her uh I think at
this point it's uh yeah that's not
surprising it's a it's a it's a losing
game but like I said uh if if the person
had actually stayed
uh I probably just would end it like
maybe in 11 or 12. yeah okay yeah but
but because the person left and it's
only in hard AI now I'm definitely just
gonna just put the boots to them yeah I
wanna I'm a little bit greedy right now
I'm like all right this game is actually
insane I could get one of the really big
scores
so uh well that's why I try for that
that's yeah some of the point of playing
it's really just to really maximize and
yeah so what what does Robinson
Industries do what uh strategy is that
Corporation for the hard AI do you
remember that one
uh I believe Robinson Industries that's
the one where you can pay four Mega
credit to actually increase your lowest
income
okay so it's a pretty
I never get excited when I see this
Corporation but it can be okay
um but it's kind of awkward because it
requires you to to have a little bit of
everything
yeah
um Olympus conference this is a card I
definitely would have wanted a lot
earlier
and now you will see this is why it
makes a lot of sense for me to keep some
cards in my hand like um
um I had this this cheap science card in
my hand what's it called
um yeah but but one of the cheap science
texts
that does nothing for me except give me
VP usually I want to play those later
because it just increases in value now
it's also worth like half a cup because
I just picked up Olympus conference
right so this goes back to the stuff we
talked about earlier like card
sequencing is is really important
for sure
so now the the next bonus that I'm
looking at is the bonus to get
on the oxygen scale okay right this is
why I'm not using my plan chip and here
is a really interesting choice
because I just picked up a herbivores
and I think this yeah I think in the
start of the Next Generation I think I'm
gonna end up actually making a few
greeneries without playing herbivores so
normally you wouldn't do this but that's
a reason for this but that's for Next
Generation in this generation I'm just
uh looking at this bonus
and I'm just trying to to still get my
green text energy up and running play my
cards so right now I'm drawing one more
card to see what I get and I think right
now I have eight plants and I believe
I'm not sure but maybe I have protected
habitat at this point
um so I might even be considering to
just not build a Greenery right now
because I want to
[Music]
um
I want to actually get the bonus in the
Next Generation if I can right okay
yeah I think uh I think this is also the
game where I I have a lot of like it's a
microbes energy but unfortunately
because I was a little bit stressed for
time or maybe I I just made a mistake uh
I I put a lot of these three microbes I
put it on decomposers but I also played
ants and ants it's actually better
because ants gives a point for two
microbes and decomposers gives a point
per three microbes
I think I'm cheating myself a little bit
out of some points by actually putting
it on decomposers rather that ends so
not good
I've got one question about oceans for
you
um where do you tend to play some do you
play some like to block people or
um what what's the The Guiding strategy
on placing oceans
uh there's a little bit of consideration
you can't really block anyone but you
can like make sure they don't get so
many good adjacency bonus tiles like if
you pace place oceans close to the
cities maybe you'll you'll give them a
nice place to play that greeneries but
mostly oceans come back comes down to
what do you need yourself do you need
the usually you want to play it next to
other oceans but the especially in the
early game there's like on this map
there's like a juicy place where you can
get two cards so you could get two
titanium or the one card is also good
especially if these long games the cards
and the titanium and stuff like this is
really good if I'm going all in for the
terraforming strategy I might place it
in the river in the middle because
there's a lot more plants available
there
um yeah something like this is what I
would consider but I would always favor
this place where you can get two cards I
think this is really good
okay so uh what are you looking at here
with the Ganymede colony
yeah normally I would play this in the
last generation but the this is simply
because
there must be a reason I'm playing it
now is it just because of satellites I
think it is I think it's because I have
so much titanium so I could just get one
more make a credit production because of
satellites which is funny yeah that's
what I'm doing so it's a it doesn't
happen very often normally you would
play this in the last generation but in
this particular case because I have so
much titanium and because I have
satellites it's okay to play it now
maybe there's a few other effects I
haven't been keeping track so maybe you
can benefit me a little bit in another
way but it's questionable to play this
right now for sure okay well if any
people see any any other questions or
things that you think you've done wrong
or things you've you've done well if
they want to add their thoughts in the
comments that would be great yeah sure I
would really welcome that um I know that
I play I I did a few mistakes that I'm
aware of but I probably also did a few
mistakes I'm I'm not aware of so if you
see anything feel free to to write it
and I'll make sure to to visit your
channel once in a while and and answer
those questions so yeah for sure that's
great now are you purposely trying to
slow the game here with the oxygen
levels or maybe I mean oceans are
getting close temperatures getting close
do you want to lengthen this out as much
as you can here yeah for sure
um I think
definitely that's what I'm gonna do I
think I'm still gonna be greedy and go
for this bonus
but the right here I'm getting colonizer
training camp and I'm getting some some
more plant production
once again I'm just keeping it all
because I want some carbs to cycle with
with my mush University it's so funny
when it happens right you just keep
everything because you're having a God
game and you just want to to cycle just
buying everything you can you can get
your hands on eh 15 yards for sure but
right now uh it's very tempting for me
to play exactly adaptive technology
because with this I can actually play
this uh
colonizer training camp because
otherwise the requirement has been
maxed normally you can only play this if
there's like five oxygen but because of
this car just Place adaptive technology
now I can actually play it
and still it's a little bit greedy to do
this rather than just taking the bonus
so so that's a lot of things here
so right now if you just get so many
choices open to you with so many cards
with such an incredible income look at
that 46.
yeah right now I'm just remembering her
because in my mind herbivores is eight
oxygen but I just played this card
adaptive technology so this means that I
I kind of place one Greenery now without
having placed other people so now I
kinda have to go for the other one
because I'm not gonna leave the bonus
one step away from him right okay but it
actually ends up being okay because for
example I also have wild enhancers I
have ecological zone so it's it's not
that bad actually and also what ends up
happening what you asked me before if
I'm gonna intentionally prolong the game
that's what I'm gonna do now right here
is where I'm deciding okay I'm actually
gonna wait a long time before I play
herbivores because what I'm gonna do I
have protected habitat so I'm just gonna
actually just Stack Up on plants and
just not terraform the the oxygen so if
you want to close the game he would have
to do all the hard work I'm not gonna
help him so this is one of the things
you can really do to actually just
prolong the game artificially Yeah just
they can just watch themselves lose
slowly yeah and normally you lose a
little bit of efficiency because you
lose a little bit of like money income
because you don't get the TR like right
sooner but in this case my engine is
huge so I don't care about that know I
just care about the game dragging out so
I can so I can go to 14 Generations
that's probably what I'm hoping for
right now would you tend to want say two
of the three variables to be closed so
that you can close the game when you
want or do you want to actually hold
back on all three of the end game
I think it's uh around the mid game you
can always spot the last parameters
that's close it could be kind of close
between two but in this case it's
definitely going to be oxygen or maybe
even water but I mean it's definitely
going to be oxygen that's the hardest
one to close so with this in mind I
don't really care about water or heat I
can I might even terraform that myself
uh I don't I don't mind that but right
now I just want to hold back my plan so
I'm not gonna terraform the oxygen too
much yeah that's okay yellow two
parameters I don't care about that much
and there's no limit on how many cards
he can have in hand in this game is
there no no no not at all no so what's
your record
I think if you go for this greedy card
strategy and and just play the long
games and usually only two player games
I think it's I don't know usually
usually if you have around 20 cards
you're you're greedy enough but I've had
a few games but just so much card
towards like even been 30 cards in my
hand or something oh wow yeah
yeah it can it can go quite crazy
so right here I picked up uh this is
just a nice place for a city so I don't
think they make a creative production
from immigrant City is such a big deal
at this point but right now I just
wanted to place it because it's a very
nice place for a city oh it's beautiful
could come into play a little bit I
could get some from this card because uh
uh yeah I know that am I having the
guard game so sooner or later that's
probably probably me is gonna build a
lot of cities on the map as well right
yeah
so uh I just picked up the other Big
Green Tech amplifier which is ecological
Zone which allows me every time I play a
plant tag I
um I can get like half a point I believe
I could get an animal worth half a point
so this is one of the other really big
ones I also got well enhancers and
decomposers so the green tax energy is
definitely up and running so now you'll
see all the plant tags that I've been I
have played some right because I uh you
can't go all in on this you also have to
play the cards when it makes sense to
you right but for sure I've been keeping
some of these cards just so I know that
all right I'm gonna play ecological Zone
and then I can play all of these plant
tech cards in my hand yeah
there's so much planning involved in
this and there's just so many options
yeah for sure
so uh I think this is also the game
where I get the most amount of of VP on
on this uh uh Predator it's gonna be I
don't know I can't remember 11 or
something it's gonna be
a lot of points on Predator but that's
because it's very good in this game
especially for the long rated games to
have one animal where the animals are
worth one Victory Point per animal
because there's a lot of other cards in
this game that can actually give animal
to another car so like large Convoy or
imported nitrogen that I have here
see your opponent has the pets card
which in our strategy guide you
mentioned is one that you like
yeah for sure pets especially if you or
someone else is going for City Pets is
of course very very good
yeah but but that one is pretty tied to
the city strategy right it's uh right
yeah normally it's cheap enough that you
would like play it in most games anyway
especially if you can also benefit from
the earth tag but the
but usually it's even better if someone
is going for cities obviously because
then it's gonna it can give you like a
lot of points I've seen games where it
gave me like 10 points or something in
peps and it's it's a lot yeah sure yeah
especially in those smaller scoring
games right relative to the the total
score it can be a lot you're just buying
everything
yeah I'm actually is this uh I think I
have 11 cards in my hand and I think I
think I only bought three this time so I
think I'm finally to the point where I'm
I'm not uh I still I have so many bad
cards on my hand already that it's okay
so I I at this point I only buy three
yeah
because you know that I'm a crazy greedy
person when I pick up tall station and
robotic Workforce these cards are still
we're generation 12 and I'm still
thinking about engine yeah because it's
so efficient for me to do rubber
I'm kind of feeling bad for this AI or
Robertson Industries is his income
everything it just pales in comparison
to yours
yeah but the funny thing is he's still
gonna he's still gonna take minor from
me because if you've noticed I haven't
actually started any awards that's also
me I was aware of him I didn't forget it
I was kind of it was completely
intentional I just I just automatically
assumed that I would win every single
award in this game because I'm having
such an insane game so it was purely
greed but as it turns out it's actually
gonna overtake me in Miner which I did
not see coming so uh I was very salty
about that one I remember
well if artificial intelligence had
emotions when he joined this game in the
position he was in he was probably just
devastated yeah yeah
it was not ready but a good thing he did
because otherwise I wouldn't have
dragged it out like this yeah because
what you're seeing right now this is
like only the crop down version of this
game which is still like one hour and
you as you can see like all the actions
is going really quickly yes it is how
long was the original yeah I think maybe
two hours or something I think I had wow
I had one hour and my opponent had one
hour so maybe almost two hours or
something so this is what happens when
you go complete god mode like normally a
cure for 30 minute games or 45 minute
games depending on how many players are
in the game yep but sometimes when you
just want to go go greedy and join a
two-player game and just
then one hour is sometimes actually
necessary because even with I skip all
the animation stuff like that you can
you can do that in the options but even
this is not enough it's still gonna be
hard to actually finish a game in in 45
minutes sometimes yeah
oh yeah this is lightning quick though I
mean yeah it is it's a
if you want you can check out the game
on my channel I also do this and I I
feel a bit guilty because
on my channel I was a little bit better
at actually explaining all the strategy
and the available plays going on but
right yeah right now when I'm talking to
you we're just having a good time I I
can't keep up with all of this that's
what I'm trying to say no kidding yeah
I'm completely distracting you my
apologies but that's fun no I think it's
impossible even even the one on my
channel it's impossible to actually talk
about all the stuff going on because
it's yeah it's just going so far fast
paced yeah it really is okay so card
resources what are we up to here you're
uh you just slapped a penalty on there
on him
yeah that's what was that something with
the animals there yeah I probably use my
Predator right oh yes okay I think I
think I I steal his fish yeah I think he
has both fish and and I don't know some
other cars but I think I steal fish
because it makes sense in my head that
the Predator actually eats fish
okay it's a little brutal brutal if he's
like eating
uh I don't know one of the other ones
like for example if you if you take if
you have a game in real life uh you have
also have this uh card from the Venus
expansion called venusian animals and
it's uh it's very I have a hard time
figuring out how it's possible for the
Predator to actually put on his
spacesuit go to Venus eat a venusian
animal go back to Mars be a bear
but the eating a fish that makes a lot
of sense to me
yeah thematically it's neat I find the
game grows on you where there's all
these different elements like at first
it just feels like you're playing a
board game and there's a million cards
but when you start to see the synergies
of the different
um themes in the game that I I really
I'm just starting to grow on me
yeah yeah for sure it's uh it's a very
well put together game for sure well
there's a reason it's it's top 10 on
Board Game Geek for who knows how many
years well probably since 2016. still
going strong yeah it's amazing actually
yeah but the I don't think it can
it can probably not keep keep its
position up there I think that's a lot
of sooner or later it's gonna it's gonna
be a little bit dated but it's uh it's
very it's very nice that it's still
going this strong there's still so many
players playing it so it's a yeah it's
already a classic
have you played brass Birmingham no no
not yet one of my friends wanted me to
play it but I haven't gotten around to
it yet yeah I think you'll enjoy that
one it's uh it's another one in the vein
of wingspan I heard it's also easy
building yeah yeah definitely maybe not
quite as in-depth as this one but uh
still pretty solid yeah I just played
Doon Imperium that's another one of the
new games that's that's well it's like a
year old by now I think but I just
played it I just I just played it for
the first time and I was very hyped it's
a it's a fun piece oh that's cool
the interforming Mars would be in your
top three games of all time yeah for
sure I mean it can right now I'm maybe a
little more interested in playing Doom
Imperium but like when everything is
said and done like of course it's I've
played so many hours in terraforming
master so it's it must be my favorite
game of all time I think that's awesome
okay we better get back to the game now
so yeah I was about to say so I am still
like robotic Workforce
it's a really good combo to use this
with the medical lab that I already
played earlier because I can I can copy
a building space a little building like
Square on the on one of the cards so
medical lab is SD card to actually combo
this card with when you're only playing
vanilla because you don't have access to
geropolis which is another good one
um so and I think it still makes sense
just because uh I'm gonna get so much
out of it and it also has a science tag
so I have so much science Synergy from
like Olympus conference and Mars
University that still makes a lot of
sense for me to play this card and then
tell stage and I also picked up this
it's like at this point I'm kind of
feeling okay maybe it's gonna be over in
generation 13. so I'm playing six foot
tall station but I'm probably still
gonna give me more than six so in this
regard it could still be worth it
um but it's uh it's very greedy to keep
going for engine but like you can see
they're so cheap and they give me other
things like like the Science Tech and
robotic Workforce so it still makes
sense to me that's right how many
actions is your opponent getting here
compared to how many you're getting
would you say
uh I don't have the numbers but for sure
I have all the advantage because I have
like you can see my action on my cards
it was like an entire screen so I had
maybe 10 20 different actions I can
actually do so no matter what's
happening he's gonna pass the generation
before me so this means that it's uh
it's entirely within my hands how I'm
gonna actually end this generation
because I'm not even slow playing at
this point this is just how far ahead I
am I have so many actions so
sort of what you dream of when you first
learn this game is just having every
choice in the universe
yeah for sure
and it's like I'm going for the car
strategy so normally you wouldn't also
well you could but normally it's you
wouldn't also like fill up the map with
like cities and greeneries but right
when you're having like I'm just doing
everything because I can yeah
to generate a big score like this uh
well it's I haven't hit the 300 on the
app but I've hit 300 in real life and on
the app I don't know I've had a couple
of games of maybe three games and 106 no
260 plus and every time you hit you get
a big score like this you just have to
go for everything because you really
have to milk the game from from for all
the points so a big component of this is
screen text energy that's like a a big
thing and obviously you can only do this
if your engine in the other game is
amazing if you have a ton of card draw
so oh wow how do you how do your friends
not rage quit on you when you get over
yeah I don't know that's a good question
it doesn't happen that often in in uh uh
normally when I play with my friends
just we are like four you know so so
normally these two player games
I had one friend doing lockdown I played
a lot of tour play games with him and we
had just had a lot of fun and played
like I don't know 20 or 30 just when the
corona started so it always came to me
my place and we played a lot of two men
instead of my mask oh no but that's
that's pretty much the only uh
the only time I actually played a lot of
two-player games in real life normally
to play a game to something I do in on
the mass app I think in real life it's
more common that when we meet up we are
like four or something yeah okay oh you
must have a good friend group then yeah
for sure a few
um so so normally
um like when it's a small player game
you're of course not gonna get big
scores like this like we talked about
because then there's gonna be fewer
Generations there's gonna be more people
actually sharing the terraform rating
that's gonna be so so the scores like
this is impossible in four player games
right yeah of course
yeah that was what surprised me most
actually but our Chad and the strategy
guide was just about every question you
seem to come back to the player count is
absolutely vital for almost every
decision in the game so that was that
was surprising I might exaggerate a
little bit like you can still play the
card strategy in a five player game if
like you have the perfect setup for it
like so it's not like
don't don't take it like you can only
play like this no you just you mostly
you play your cards but you really have
to have this in the back of your head
like some strategies are really suited
for for shorter or or fewer player
numbers and some strategies are really
suited for for larger player numbers for
instance the the terraforming strategy
where I just go all Inland terraforming
you can do like a middle middle road
kind of thing in two player games but
but in in like if you're gonna all in on
terraforming and you are doing nothing
else then you should not play two player
because it simply doesn't work you can't
close the game that fast so the other
guy is gonna have enough time either way
with his greedy engine and it's not
gonna take so long to for him to
actually beat you yeah so uh yeah player
number is definitely very important now
why did you play your city right beside
the other City there um was that was
that the best place you could find or
um
are you talking about on the bottom of
the screen yeah that's right yeah I
don't think that's the city I played it
next to that would have been illegal
unless I had some I think it's a special
time but uh it's it's really hard to see
in the on this it's one of the one of
the few critiques I have with it but um
um I think this just made a lot of sense
I think my point right now is I want to
first of all I want to see if he
actually closes the game here at 13 if
he does not then I'm Gonna Make It Go to
14.
um that that's the number one priority
and secondly if it goes to 14 then then
I definitely want all of the good City
spots the city spots is uh like you can
see I don't have that many cars anymore
right so if I do get another generation
I'm I really want to spend all of my
plans and all of my mega credits but
actually cities all over the map because
this is the way I can get points right
now
and this Lane claim up here it's
actually kind of cool because normally
you play a land claim so actually annoy
the other guy but this Lane claim makes
it like not a hundred percent but almost
100 sure that this city I I will get
this city like there's no questions
asked because normally if you play a
game claim the other guy can just put
something right next to your lane claim
but in this case it would be illegal
because the way I place my Series so
this Lane claim is actually kind of
clever I think
and like you probably saw I finally
played my
um what's it called the Bambi yeah oh
right yes the urban RCs
and so this is a live like look how many
I even spent some plans but I'm still 62
plants left so now I'm like
yeah I'm I I just want cities I just
wanna finally spend all of my plans and
uh as soon as he passes I'm just gonna
terraform everything until there's like
one step left because then I get the
maximum out of the last available Tia as
well yeah yeah it's kind of it's kind of
a thick move to be honest but once again
uh the guy left so it's it's only hard
AI so I don't feel bad about it yeah
exactly
just put it to them
[Music]
yeah so um
yeah I'm still just like using my
actions once again it's not even slow
playing because it's I just have to go
through all of my action I'm not even
like taking only one action on my turn
and then passing right it would be
totally viable if I did but in this case
I have so many actions I don't even have
to do that I'm just going through the
motions waiting for him to pass and then
as soon as he passes I'm gonna like oh
wow yeah
terraform everything except for one step
and finally spent my 63 playing totally
here seems like ants are doing all right
for you there
yeah for sure it's a good card just
because
um so it's it's not often you actually
get to steal from another especially in
two player game it's a little bit
unlikely that he has
um something to steal yeah but just the
fact that it's a microcut that can wear
microbes are worth one Victor Point per
two microbe I believe in vanilla and
this is vanilla and
in this meter there's like a novenusian
insects or another card that can
actually do this so it's only ants where
the insects are actually worth this much
so this is why it's a it's a good card
especially when I have so many cards
that actually this is
it just takes forever to get through all
of your actions yeah it really does and
this is like if you look at the first
like you barely have time to actually
introduce and and like establish cast oh
we actually had generation three or
something and uh and now now it's the
last generation maybe the next one as
well is yeah so many actions so this is
why it ends up saying one hour even
though we cropped it down and like
rushed through it and stuff like this
yeah yeah it's fun to see though it's
sexy enjoy to watch it
yeah it's uh for sure it's it's uh so
now the the water has been closed I
believe I actually helped uh that's
right I can see that he's been closing
um
I think he's passed maybe that's what
I'm looking at but if he's not passed
yet then
I believe I I got a little bit in on the
water at the end
uh because it's it's gonna be oxygen
that's the last one to to close the game
um
and finally I'm I'm about to to spend my
plans I think this is uh he just plays
the city like in the middle of my two
cities he had a cop that could do that
what's it called
immigrant something I don't know yeah oh
actually was lava tube settlement so it
has to be placed on a volcano that's
what happened okay
um yeah but the
but by him doing that it's of course
very annoying for me but then I had this
other card commercial district and now I
can place this next to the three cities
and also I'll get one more City on my
land claim so it ends up being okay
because now my commercial district is
gonna it's gonna be great
this is fun yeah you've just got so many
plants there yeah it's uh and I still
haven't played insect yet it's uh it's
quite it's a lot maybe it's the most
plants I've ever had on the game it's a
very insane I'd say yeah that's awesome
also I have this card that gives me like
one plant per City so yeah this is gonna
get crazy man
so uh maybe it passed now yeah I I
checked the lock and I okay he finally
passed so now here we go let's go now
we're finally gonna I'm only gonna get
two plants now because once again I want
to look closer to 14. so I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna spend my 47 plans until
the next Generation yeah
but I think uh
I don't know why I get energy production
there must be a reason
um I wonder but the uh for sure it's
insects I should be looking at right now
and also this one normally you play this
in the last generation but right now I
already have all of the green tags in
look at this green text energy I get
from this card
and also it's because it's one more clam
tag for the m6 and I didn't have any
impactful beta cards to play so right
now I think I'm at the point to just
sell three cards
so probably yeah I have three bad cards
are you imagine I would still underwrap
detonation Great Escape and Consortium
and
and one more so I can just play insects
I think that's what I'm gonna do
yeah and then biomass combusters it
gives me minus victory points so it
makes no sense to play at this point
yep that is a lot of plans
for sure
in the awards there's only one award so
far
yeah this yeah this is this is actually
the computer style of this one this is
like the miner so I I
I'm really salty
I had to go to that one because I
thought I would just automatically get
all three
gotta let him have a bone at least at
least one minor success
yeah and the thing that really hurts is
that I I just did it because I'm greedy
but what's gonna end up happening is
that the
I'm gonna have a lot of Mega current
left over when this game is done so the
fact that it didn't just it take three
Milestones is like ah it hurts so much
because it's not even it's not even all
right I didn't get the award but then I
saved some money no it didn't matter
because
and because I'm gonna end up having so
much gold left over oh it's insane you
were just at 139 Mega credits
yeah yeah that's awesome
and right now it's uh
um what I really should be doing is just
fill up the map as soon as I can like
get the last maybe you won't see there
for one two but yeah
just get the green race as soon as yeah
I'm getting one more City
it makes sense uh this this one I'm not
why would I place on top of my Lane
claim that one is secured so that was a
mistake I think that's a little bit of
uh things I should do before and and
after like right now I'm getting the
awards but I think
basically I just don't want to repeat
the mistakes from earlier by not by not
taking the world but really what I
should be doing is fill up the map
um
but it doesn't matter that much at this
point because
he will have he will get like a fuse
maybe one city and a few greeneries and
there's little I can do to stop him he
will do that so it doesn't matter that
much but just from a technical point of
view I should really be filling up the
map
you have 14 actions down there available
yeah that's once again like in the other
Generations I started with my action
because I wanted to to see what my
opponent is doing is he gonna close the
game but in this last generation because
I'm literally running out of ways I can
get VP so this is why it's in impeccable
it's really important that I just get as
many greeneries down on the map as soon
as possible because
if he actually gets greeneries down
like and I still have greeneries left in
my head it would be annoying it would be
annoying points out the window so I just
have to fill up the map as soon as
possible
hmm because I'm I'm still gonna have
leftover Mega credits when when the game
is done
so I think I technically I misplayed a
little bit at the start of this
generation I did a lot of stuff that I
didn't really have to do technically
what I should have done is just fill up
the map yeah right yeah do you think you
would have scored that many more points
doing that though
no it's it's not the biggest deal I
think when when everything is said it's
done he's probably just gonna get like a
few greeneries a few cities and maybe
he's gonna run out of gold way before
this comes into play but technically I
should have filled up the map sooner
rather than later
so I I I might have been missing like a
little bit but it's hard to say I would
have to check his profile to or his game
to actually see how much uh
Mega credits he has how many cities he
can make right yeah
but it ends up being
hmm
I got eight eight plants left in the
spot for one more Greenery so it ends up
like all of the plants I've been saving
up and it just works out completely it's
a little bit funny yeah it's it's really
fun to watch you actually just seen so
many go down yeah
um
so hopefully I start putting this on
ends yeah nice
that's probably the biggest mistake I
did is that I I couldn't decomposer so
long time instead of ants right yeah and
the other big mistake was not starting
all of the awards that's like five
points out the window right there
other than that I'm pretty happy with
how I played it's only it's only minor
things I did wrong I think really is
it's really hard to improve on this
yeah but it's a
uh I'm uh
once again I'm the bad kind of a
perfectionist so when I make small
misplaces like this it really annoys me
you know what I mean
that's right we'll just gloss over it
let's just focus on the good
so right now it's pretty straightforward
I I did I filled up the map that was I I
started the last award so there's
there's no rush anymore and I was just
spend use all of my actions and
hopefully the cards I have in my hand
will draw some even more impactful cards
because I still have 79 Mega credits so
yeah you're just trying to find ways to
blow your millionaire status here yeah
so how many I think yeah I've fallen 14
Predators that's probably also the the
biggest amount I've ever had on
Predators that's a lot that's awesome
are there a lot of interactions do you
find Direct interactions between players
in these engine building games or does
it tend to be more people playing their
own boards
I think people are like some people
think that there's a lot of
some people think this is a solitaire
game where it's only it's only like you
just play your thing multiplayer is so
low yeah
and and to a point they're correct
because you cannot hit your opponents
that much
but that's also one other thing I like
about this game you cannot just like
destroy a player if he said right yeah
so I think the amount of clearance
action is actually pretty good in this
game I think I like it a lot the way it
is
um but the
there's actually a lot of things you can
do like for example the biggest thing
that separates
um
a mediocre player from a new player is
is probably just figuring out who got
the bigger engine and is it in my best
interest to actually drag out the game
or is it in my best interest to close
the game that's really nice
um because
yeah that's the biggest way you can hurt
degree opponent is just to close the
game basically just finish it up yep
yeah other than that yeah you can burn a
little bit of plans and you can take
away like there's some really damaging
cards if you like take away one titanium
production or play hackers on the first
generation that could actually mess up a
player so much but but other than that
it's not that much it's not that
impactfully what you can do
and so I think it's a I like I like the
game the way it is I think it's a very
good balance
and of course like contesting Milestones
like it's also a big thing consisting
bonuses like if you're if you're playing
against Bad opponents like one of the
reasons
uh this was also a very very good game
for me is of course that
um
I don't know how good the pla I'm
imagining the player wasn't like that
good the one I played against but it's
really hard to say because I have a God
game so maybe
you know maybe maybe the guy could just
skate up gave up or something you can't
really judge like this but but when I'm
playing against an AI he's probably not
gonna make optimal plays so that's right
yeah you seem to be just crashing them
on every count except that one except
that that minor thing that one yeah one
award it's all right so yeah I'm gonna
pass the game with 33 Mega credits so it
it doesn't happen very often but we are
not playing with Venus so I can't I
cannot even just buy two Venus or
something it's a it's weird it's rare
that you run out of options to dominate
yeah it is it is okay so tell me about
the end game scoring here
well let's see how much I get on points
I think maybe 110 or something
and 50 of those is like on top of cards
so that's the green tax energy is how
I'm getting like the most points yeah
150 victory points on cars and that's
that's basically because like at least
half of that is green tax energy and
stuff I just put on top of my cards so
that's a big one and then because I'm
having a God game then obviously cities
in greeneries is also really good yeah
me too yeah terraforming rating was
pretty solid I mean I think in our last
game your entire score was 29 or 79 and
yeah yeah exactly it's very hard to
compare but this is what I mean that
it's entirely different manner if you
play two player and especially if it
goes leads like this it's a greedy 14
generation game or if it's a 9th
generation game it's like totally
different so this is why it's so hard to
actually compare scores and terraformers
you have to take into account number of
players you have to take into account so
many different things how many
expansions are you playing with that's
your video to get high scores if you
also have colonies and and some of the
other expansions so it's there's so many
things you have to take into account so
this is why in wingspan is always like
all right this score is good because the
meta is always the same it's always this
amount of terms it's always
well it can vary a little bit if you're
if you're like against one or two or
three opponents on wingspan but
basically you always have the option of
creating the same level of score in
terms of mass is entirely different
because it just comes down to how many
players how many generations do we have
so many things yeah
well it was a pleasure watching you
dominate I really appreciate you sharing
your strategies and all your thoughts
with us so thank you so much for joining
us today sure thanks for having me
remember get out there get gaming be
legendary
foreign